tu es sûr
oui c'est une belle aventure
le premier homme sur la lune qui me
fascine ou peu la mission qu'on a choisi
est ce si difficile
elle exige un tel niveau d'avancées
technologiques qu on va être obligé de
repartir à zéro
ce n'est que lorsqu'on maîtrisera ses
tâches qu on envisagera d'atterrir sur
la lune
ça
neil si ce vol est un succès vous
entrerez dans l'histoire
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire nous ne
prévoyons rien d'autre qu'un succès sur
ce vol
ben dis-donc c'est une sacrée bête ça va
nous pulvérisé comme une bombe atomique
si ça explose
le module n'est pas encore assez sûr
c'est ici qu'on doit échouer si on veut
pas échouer là haut c'est pas un vol
comme les autres
tu vas pas au bureau je dois revenir à
la maison
il y à des risques mais on a bien
l'intention de revenir
couteau suisse un consensus c'est une
blague
vous
d'ailleurs c'est bon
vous êtes déjà demandé si ça valait le
sacrifice financier et humain
on regarde le ciel dit si on pense pas
trop à tout ça mais explorer l'espace ça
change la perspective
ça permet de voir des choses qu'on
aurait dû voir depuis longtemps là il ya
un gros problème
on maîtrise la situation
vous êtes et boy scout vous ne maîtrisez
rien du tout